Adesso farò una pelliccia stupenda con
te Grazie la prendo
volentieri ti rompo mille pezzi e no non
puoi Io sono Crudelia
Deon e in questa casa odore di cane farò
la mia nuova
pelliccia tenebro Oh eh Eccomi mia
signora scusi ritardo eh comunque odori
di cane Capisco che non mi lavo spesso
però mi sembra un po' offensivo eh Stai
zitto va bene stavo dicendo in questa
casa Sento odore di cane perfetto
possiamo fare una nuova pelliccia Ah
così diventerà ancora più bella Io sono
già bella oh no no Sì assolutamente
volevo dire quello eh Però vabbè andiamo
a cercare can Ecco sì facciamo Prim
Speriamo di trovare un dalmata Io adoro
la pelliccia di Dalmata Speriamo di
trovare davvero qualche dalmata senò in
mancanza di cane la mia padrona la
pelliccia se la fa con la mia di
pelle è un dalmata non è un dalmata
stupido lo voglio è perfetto per fare la
mia pelliccia bene vai a prenderlo
perché io perché io non lo faccio vai tu
Ma no vai va bene vi qui piccolino forza
vieni dai dai non ti faccio niente sei
buono sì vieni Uh Ehi piano eh non
faccio niente Eh vai ti faccio fare una
passeggiatina Dai vieni qua mia signora
però ti Dio la mano posso fare tutto io
se proprio la mammoletta e c'ho paura
magari questo mi morde a posto Adesso
farò una pelliccia stupenda con
te
lo vedi l'hai fatto scappare Tutta colpa
tua È andato via da solo L'ho fatto
niente Sei un buon Annulla sempre colpa
mia Qua va bene mia signora che si fa
vai a
prenderlo dai qua l'avevamo quasi preso
ma adesso ci toccherà andare fuori per
prendere quel cane e avere finalmente la
mia
pelliccia
Merlino ino Eh ma chi ha lasciato Questi
libri a
terra Che strano è come se fosse entrato
qualcuno in casa Vitale
Vitale gianita Hai buttato tu Questi
libri a terra eh No non li ho buttati io
perché avrei dovuto c'erano questi libri
a terra in più non trovo Merlino dove
sarà andato Merlino forse è entrato
qualcuno in casa No dici che sono
entrati i ladri ho paura Ho sentito
rumore là fuori andiamo a vedere
ok cagnolino che schifo la campagna io
voglio tornare nel mio attico
lussuoso questo verde non mi piace No è
pieno di insetti qua mia signora sono
insett fobico Che schifo Dobbiamo
trovare il cane
forza Spero non si rovini la mia pellic
qua andiamo da quella parte Andiamo Ehi
Ehi guarda c'è qualcuno lì Chi sono
quelle persone super ambe E cosa stanno
cercando ma soprattutto perché sono
vestite così e sono vestite un po'
strani Sì E cosa ci fanno a casa nostra
sono degli intrusi andiamo a parlarci sì
scacci
amoli che cosa ci fate voi qui e chi
siete Dateci Il vostro cane nessuno si
farà male a parte il cane
belliccia il nostro Merlino e Perché
volete il nostro cane che cosa dovete
farci io non lo do il nostro cane forse
voi non sapete con chi chi avete a che
fare io sono Crudelia Deon e con il
vostro cane voglio farci la mia nuova
pelliccia
Rino Lino
consegnatore No no cosa la pelliccia di
Merlino Ma siete pazzi Merlino dove
sei Troppo tardi Ormai il cane è nostro
e ne faremo una splendida
pelliccia andiamo forza bravissimo
adesso and amoca a casa Così faremo la
nostra
pelliccia andatevene subito da casa
nostra non vi vogliamo qui S S Sì e
lasciate in pace il nostro Merlino
Esatto troppo tardi il mio assistente
tenebro l'ha già preso Sì ce l'ho io
forza vieni qua mia signora se dovesse
avanzare un po' di questo bel manto
potrei farsi un paio di guanti eh C
fredda le mani eh Non per altro vedremo
Oh no PR Marino Ho un'idea ho capito una
cosa Ti ricordi che abbiamo visto quei
libri che sono caduti credo che i
cattivi si siano sprigionati da quei
libri e infatti Sembrano proprio i
cattivi della Carica dei 101 sono usciti
dal libro quindi ho un'idea per farli
tornare nei libri ma tu devi aspettare
qua e devi distrarli mentre io torno ok
ci riesci ci provo Sì sì ce la devo fare
ce la devo fare inventati qualcosa per
distrarli così non porteranno via
Merlino Ok ok per Merlino Sì sì ce la
posso fare eh Eh signori cattivi eh
insomma voglio dire datemi la vostra
attenzione vi devo vi devo mostrare una
cosa un modo un sistema per prendere
tutti i cani del vicinato tutti quelli
del quartiere Praticamente è un balletto
molto semplice così voi attirerete a voi
tutti i cani e e potrete arrivare a 101
ce l'avete già uno ne prenderete 100
dovete fare praticamente questo tipo di
Balletta
Uh Allora devi con le punte con le punte
dei piedi devi saltellare hai capito
popetti un po' così anche sì S Bravo
aemo un sacco di cani mia signora Eh
però devi stare attento eh SC devi
introdurre mentre fai questo
l'abbaglio Ragazzi ho preso il mio libro
La città stregata che ha i suoi poteri
ormai li conoscete dagli altri video con
questo libro catturerò i cattivi e li
farò tornare alla loro storia di
appartenenza e cioè la carica dei 101
Speriamo che funzioni anche questa volta
3 2
ah
Sì ha funzionato Merlino Brava fatta li
ho presi con con il libro Ehi aspetta un
momento non era solo un libro che è
caduto nella libreria quindi potrebbero
esserci altri cattivi qua in giro dici
andiamo a controllare se c'è qualcun
[Musica]
altro è rimasto un libro a terra Questo
vuol dire che potrebbe esserci ancora un
cattivo delle storie dei libri qua in
giro per casa è meglio se teniamo gli
occhi aperti eh Ma voi avete cliccato mi
piace se non avete ancora cliccato mi
piace cliccate subito mi piace e se non
avete ancora il mio libro La città
stregata è ora disponibile on e in
libreria Ecco qua un messaggio segreto
per voi che potete tradurre con
l'alfabeto segreto che trovate dentro al
libro Ma dov'è finito Vitale
Vitale Vitale dove sei
E tu chi sei la vuoi questa mela è buona
Vieni mangiala
Oh una bellissima mela succosa Certo che
la accetto poi una persona così
affidabile Grazie la prendo
volentieri
dolce ha un sapore un po' strano Però
continuo a
mangiarla Bravo mangiane un altro morso
Sì sì la mangio tutta Bravo un altro
morso forza tutta la mangio
tutta proprio buona
buona non mi sento tanto
bene la mela avvelenata ha funzionato
Ah ma dove mi trovo non sono più nella
mia fiamma Ah devo trovare al più presto
la mia
amata una mela una mela morsa Allora
Biancaneve deve essere da queste parti
Sì devo andare a
salvarla Ma dove sarà Ah sono
preoccupatissimo Ah e tu chi sei non sei
la mia Biancaneve
Ehi
ehi Biancaneve dove sei vitale E tu chi
sei tu chi sei no tu chi sei e io io
sono il principe azzurro e Sono alla
ricerca della mia amata Biancaneve non
la trovo che cosa hai fatto Vitale Io no
Io non ho fatto niente L'ho trovato così
Vitale Sveglia sveglia perché non si
sveglia Che cosa hai fatto credo che
abbia mangiato la mela avvelenata della
strega Grimilde della strega del mio
regno che voleva uccidere la mia
Biancaneve con lo stesso sistema una
mela avvelenata Devi aiutarmi a trovare
Biancaneve ti prego Ho capito siamo
nella fiama di Biancaneve devo
assolutamente salvare Vitale Ma allora
dobbiamo subito trovare la strega ti
aiuterò io così magari potrei riportarmi
da Biancaneve ok Se mi aiuti ti
riporterò nella tua fiaba originale so
come fare farò di tutto per
aiutarti specchio specchio delle mie Bra
Ecco la strega Chi è la più bella del
reame di certo non tu Ma chi ti credi di
essere con quel porro sul naso
poi Ma come ti permetti ti rompo mille
pezzi e no non puoi altrimenti avrai 7
anni di
sfortuna Ma guarda tu che insolente
Forse abbiamo scoperto il suo punto
debole la vanità Guarda come si Vanda è
vero un vanitosa non accetta di non
essere la più bella del reame Dobbiamo
inventarci qualcosa per sconfiggerla
sfruttando il fatto che conosciamo il
suo punto debole Hai qualcosa in mente
forse forse potremmo usare degli insulti
così si offenderebbe non so se
funzionerà ma proviamoci dobbiamo
salvare Vitale Sì e anche Biancaneve va
bene
riproviamo specchio specchio delle mie
brame chi è la più bella del
reame ancora non sei tu e Ora basta
Lasciami
dormire Ah specchio inutile ora basta
eliminerò chiunque Io incontrerò così
diventerò io la più bella del
reame Questo è il nostro momento andiamo
forza Samo qui per sconfiggerli strega
Oh bene Avevo proprio voglia di
eliminare
qualcuno E allora preparati stupida
strega stupida va bene Sì no dovresti
impegnarti un po' di più con gli
insulti stupida a me come usi
maleodorante Principe di puzzol
Landia puzzol
Landia brutta befana schifosa puzzona
puzzolente vecchia e scema brutta vipera
e at al sole del deserto fatto di
scorregge nere come la morte basta
basta Bravo sta funzionando continua
così scema bacucca di una vecchia in
carriola con le piattole sotto le acelle
pelose con i peli color funghi ammuffiti
che puzzano di cipolla affumicata e i
granchi basta Non è vero Io sono la più
bella del reame Dai dammi una Guarda dle
questo Oh sei più brutta di un gabinetto
intasato da un extraterrestre con
quattro sederi che quando scorreggiano
tutti assieme formano una nuvoletta di
gas che dice brutta strega mia fette
cosa state dicendo No non è
vero tocca a me anch'io ho qualcosa da
dire volevi sapere chi è la più bella
del reame Ebbene sei tu se tutti in
questo reame fossero
ciechi Non è vero hai capito brutta
bacucca No basta basta mi sento debole
perfetto Questo è il momento
giusto No
no presa Ho riportato la strega della
sua fiaba Grazie Anita Ci hai salvati
Guarda quello è l'antidoto Usalo per
salvare quel Vitale il momento di
tornare nella mia fiaba così potrò
salvare Biancaneve non ti preoccupare Ci
penso io ora con il libro ti riporterò
nella tua fiama originale Grazie e buona
fortuna
grazie Ok abbiamo risolto anche questa
storia non ci resta che salvare Vitale
adesso Sveglia sveglia Vitale mele m
dolci Ma come dolci mele Svegliati ti ho
dato l'antidoto eh Che è successo c'era
C'era una bravissima signora qui che mi
ha offerto delle mele dov'è andata
Magari ha qualcos'altro da mangiare Ma
che bravissima signora Quella era la
strega di Biancaneve Ah e comunque
abbiamo risolto anche questa storia Ah
non mi sono accorto di niente forse
stavo dormendo Sì infatti tu hai dormito
tutto il tempo Comunque anche questa
avventura è risolta e voi se non avete
ancora il nostro nuovo libro La città
stregata andate subito a prenderlo e ora
vi lasciamo Qua quattro caselline su cui
cliccare cliccate su quello che
preferite e buona visione Ciao
[Musica]
ah